Before we address the question of what the potential energy is let's just take a moment
and imagine what's going to happen when we release this charge q.
Well, if this charge is positive, it's going to accelerate in this direction.
If this particle accelerates, it's going to gain kinetic energy.
And we know from Unit 4 that the change in kinetic energy of the particle
is equal to the work done on the particle.
And what's this work equal to? Well the work is just the force
that the electric field is applying on the charge over the distance that it's being applied over.
This means that if the charge moves all the way over to the negative plate, then the work done
by the field will equal the force applied by the field times that distance x.
And what's this force equal to?
Well we know that's just equal to this electric field strength times the charge of the particle.
All right so putting this together, we found that the change in kinetic energy
is equal to the electric field strength times the charge of the particle
times the distance it moves through x.
All right. Now let's use conservation of energy to relate this change
in kinetic energy to a change in potential energy.
In this case because there aren't any extra forces doing any work on the charge
only the field is doing the work we know that the change in kinetic energy
is in fact exactly equal to the change in potential energy.
And the change in potential energy is just equal to the difference
between the original potential energy and the final potential energy.
We know that if the charge moves all the way to the negative plate,
it has 0 potential energy so we can cancel out this term, which leaves us
that the change in kinetic energy is exactly equal to the original potential energy.
We know that the change in kinetic energy is equal to Eqx
so this gives us that the original potential energy was equal the Eqx.
This is our nice formula for the potential energy of a charge in a constant electric field.
And you might notice something really cool about this.
This formula is actually effectively the same as our gravitational formula mgh.
In this equation, the gravitational field strength is replaced with the electric field strength.
And the mass of the particle is replaced with the charge of the particle and the distance away
from the negative plate is essentially the same as the height above the ground.
What we see here is that this formula is completely analogous
to our gravitational potential energy formula, which is awesome.
All right. If you are able to get this equation, great job.